[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre el día internacional de
la conmemoración del holocausto cada 27
de enero se rinde tributo a la memoria
de las víctimas
díaz declarado por la onu en 2005 es por
ello que nos acompaña desde argentina
jonathan carsen vaughn director del
museo del holocausto en ese país gracias
por estar con nosotros señor cárcel
mount cuál es la importancia de esta
conmemoración
bueno la importancia es que el mundo ha
decidido desde 2005 recordar la llegada
de los soviéticos outfits como un evento
trascendental para toda la humanidad y
eso tiene que ver con que el holocausto
se ha erigido como un genocidio
paradigmático e instalado en la memoria
colectiva del mundo y es parte de este
deseo que la humanidad dijo nunca más
todavía hay mucho por hacer pero es
importante que se recuerde y se homenaje
a las víctimas de la shoah que han sido
fundamentales para la construcción de
esta memoria colectiva
el holocausto no sólo afectó a los
países donde se cometieron crímenes
nazis también tuvo repercusiones en
muchos otros lugares del mundo como en
argentina que están haciendo ustedes
desde el museo para no olvidar lo que
pasó en los campos de concentración y el
exterminio
bueno desde el museo trabajamos
fuertemente para construir una mirada
como bien ha dicho a alan desde la
argentina contando que sucedió aquí
durante el holocausto y después del
holocausto tanto desde la ayuda que se
brindó y se intentó brindar a las
víctimas así en europa como también a la
ciudad de llegadas refugiados por parte
de la comunidad judía local y también
que acciones hubo en los gobiernos de
aquel tiempo por el otro lado
lamentablemente tanto a argentina oa
distintos países del mundo llegaron
criminales de guerra hubo partidos nazis
entonces debemos contar los distintos
aspectos que vinculan a nuestro país ya
nuestro continente con la tragedia señor
carsen vaughn como le están rindiendo
homenaje a los que sobrevivieron el
holocausto
bueno a través de nuestras redes
sociales a través de nuestras acciones
actos conmemorativos mensajes vídeos
reflexión con historias de
sobrevivientes que han sido
fundamentales en esta construcción
nosotros el museo del resultado de la
construcción que los oriente se han
hecho de la memoria y nuestro mejor
homenaje contar sus historias para que
funcionen como un aprendizaje para toda
la sociedad esas historias no deben
repetirse y ese es nuestro compromiso
como generación trabajar día a día para
educar y que no vuelva a repetirse un
aussies nunca más precisamente ampliando
este tema desde la educación cómo se
lucha contra el antisemitismo
bueno a través de fortalecer la
convivencia entre las distintas
religiones entre los distintos pueblos
naciones culturas fortalecer la
diferencia como un valor y con no como
una amenaza eso es fundamental para
entender para convivir democráticamente
y para protegernos entre todos de
aquellos discursos de odio que fomentan
la segregación y que fomentan sobre todo
la estigmatización de distintos grupos
contra eso luchamos día a día entre esos
grupos lamentablemente el pueblo judío
ha sufrido el antisemitismo y trabajamos
también para que el antisemitismo
desaparezca en algún momento en el
futuro próximo el holocausto como está
en la resolución de la uv no será
siempre una advertencia para todo el
mundo de los peligros del odio el
fanatismo el racismo y los prejuicios
que falta por aprender en el planeta
porque crímenes atroces siguen
ocurriendo al igual que los discursos de
otros
bueno eso tiene que ver con que los
seres humanos no aprendemos tan rápido
como nos gustaría pensar la memoria es
un ejercicio permanente las conductas
humanas son muy frágiles somos muy
maleables mucho más de lo que nosotros
suponemos y entonces es importante que
la alerta sea permanente si hoy esas
condiciones terribles de la humanidad
hubieran desaparecido sólo nos daríamos
a recordar y homenajear pero
lamentablemente todavía tenemos mucho
para aprender como los seres humanos en
un planeta que es cada vez más chico más
complejo debemos estar alertas para que
estos genocidios no se desaten porque
una vez que comienzan es muy difícil
frenarlos entonces tenemos que tener
alertas tempranas para ello
muchas gracias por esta gran dedicación
por sus palabras por su análisis
jonathan carsen vaughn él es director
del museo del holocausto en argentina y
muchas gracias a ustedes por su compañía
siga con más mucho más en francés 24
[Música]